foreign
good afternoon welcome back I'm
delighted to introduce Vegeta who will
start our fourth uh tutorial series uh
and this time it's on fine grain
complexity uh you know these are the
things I learned a lot when trying to
optimize queries in Optimizer so
personally I'm very excited to get this
started
thank you let me know if you can't hear
me I can talk louder
okay so some of you have seen some
versions of this talk hopefully maybe
it's a little different from usual but
for many of you you may have not seen it
so I'm really excited to share this
stuff with you okay so this is one of
four lectures that will give me and my
student ninja who's over there my former
student Nicole who will be a professor
at Michigan soon okay so
I'll start what is the main goal of
algorithms research well we have a bunch
of fundamental problems we want to find
the best algorithm for them and usually
this is in the worst case uh and what
what best means is usually the fastest
running time
what is the fastest running time let's
say your input size is in typically you
have to read the input so the best we
typically want to get is linear time
um and
the good news is for many many problems
we've gotten there we have even this
year we've gotten new and new algorithms
for all sorts of problems we keep
getting close to linear
and we have a lot of these techniques
and we keep combining them inventing new
ways to do things and adding more and
more things to this box
yeah
unfortunately there's a lot of problems
for which we're still stuck on and this
comes to a very old quote from gerdo who
is thinking about exhaustive search you
know for all the problems we work on
there are usually an NP and if they're
an NP there is some algorithm to solve
them there's some exhaustive search
algorithm that's defined by the verifier
of the NP problem and the question is
can we actually do better than this
exhaustive search out
uh and often uh we just don't know if
you can do better and this is extremely
frustrating if you work on algorithms
because we really want to get something
and yet the stupid dissolution you come
up with you can't even beat that
what are the type of problems that we
get stuck on with our techniques well
they're all over the place from very
diverse areas some from databases some
in logic uh very important you have to
solve them in practice often you look at
this problem and you say you know what
I'm just gonna throw dynamic programming
on it okay it works but then when you
analyze the running time is Something
Bad
quadratic
right and sometimes it's two to the end
often this is extremely slow and in
practice you would never run such an
algorithm even though it's you can
immediately come up with it
and you go in the literature and you see
a lot of people have tried to solve
these problems forever and ever and they
all came up with the same algorithm you
did and nobody did better and you don't
know why
here's a canonical example so we all
know the case set problem you have n
Boolean variables and a bunch of Clauses
so it's in conjunctive normal form and
clauses all of them are orders of
literals and you want to know is there
Boolean assignment to the variable so
for every Clause at least one of the
literals is set to true
and of course
because it's a problem in NP there is a
Brute Force exhaustive search algorithm
which is try all possible assignments to
the variable so plug them in and there
you go when you try all possible
solutions you know whether there is a
satisfying assignment or not
and this running time would be 2 to the
end the number of Boolean assignments so
the variables times the time to plug in
which is usually linear time and the
size of the formula
what is the best known algorithm
for every width of a clause K is the
maximum number of literals per Clause K
there is an algorithm that runs in 2 to
the N minus some constants times n
divided by K and people improve on this
constant
and as a polynomial and the number of
Clauses but unfortunately
this over here disappears as K growth
so as the the size of the Clauses grows
this running time goes to 2 to the N
which we could have gotten just by doing
exhaustive search
which is again one of these frustrating
things
and to repeat we don't have a 2 to the N
to the 1 minus Epsilon time algorithm
where Epsilon works for all K so this
algorithm works for all things the same
Epsilon
it's an embarrassing open problem
to do this here's another hard problem
okay we know KSAT is hard because you
know it's NP hard but this problem is
going to be hard what is this problem
you're given two strings and N letters
over some alphabet let's say a c t g and
I want to know if the the
largest length of a sequence that
appears in both of them so a sequence is
not a it's a string but it does they
don't have to be consecutive letters so
you can skip
okay so for example for these two the
blue the blue letters form a sequence
that appears in both and it happens to
be the longest it's an alignment problem
so you can think of as aligning the
letters of the uh the maximum length
sequence and then there's some things
that don't match and you want to
maximize the matching letters in the
alignment you can put gaps here to skip
some letters
so this has a lot of applications and
spell Checkers and computational biology
where you might when you where you might
have like DNA sequences you want to know
how similar they are all sorts of
applications of where you want to
compute similarity of sequences and what
do you do you use dynamic programming
and we teach it in our algorithms
courses you can use dynamic programming
to solve this problem in quadratic time
in the number of letters in the sequence
N squared the best known algorithm is
from the 80s by Madison Patterson and it
runs in N squared divided by log N
squared so we can do a little better
than N squared but it's not much better
there is no N squared to the one minus
Epsilon time algorithm
okay so this is similar to sat in the
sense that there's some easy algorithm
that runs in t to the end time yet we
can't get to T of n to the one minus
Epsilon times
some seeming barrier
for our techniques here's a problem from
databases okay so here you have a
database which is a from the strings of
length and binary strings and your
queries are
so this is deep actually anyway
so this is the dimension is this so now
you want to you you have n queries and
each queries is also a string of length
d uh but the string can have a star so
zero one is star and what you want to
know for every query is there something
in the name of the base that matches
this what is a match if the in the query
in the ith position you have a star star
matches both zero and one if it's a one
you have the the Y the string in the
database also have to have a one there
and if it's a zero it also has to has a
zero for example over here zero one one
zero one matches this string here with
the Stars so the star matches everything
zero matches at zero one matches with
star so we want the in the batch partial
match probably we want to know for every
query is there some match in the
database for it
um how fast can you solve it well
there's two very simple algorithms the
first one is uh well for every query and
every every single database check if
they match that runs in N squared times
D times so the size of the databases and
the dimension is D for every pair the
number of pairs is N squared D is the
length of the the sequence again sorry
about the typo here and so N squared
times D is very easy is the Brute Force
solution you can also pre-process all
possible queries in advance and because
the dimension is D there's 2 to the D
queries roughly and then you can check
uh whenever you get a query you check
whether what if pre-process works
so
um there's actually a better algorithm
if your dimension is c times log n
then you could get n to the 2 minus 1
over order log C but if C is a constant
this is less than that less than
quadratic but if C is not less than a
constant then then this is not sub
quadratic
so again we have this issue that there's
no n to the 2 minus Epsilon time
algorithm no for this problem even
though N squared times D is very easy e
and D is very tiny
okay
so to recap there's many many of these
problems there you can usually come up
with a simple algorithm analyze it and
you get some running time T event
but we don't have a t of n to the one
minus Epsilon time algorithm for any of
them and the question for me that's
interesting to me is are those problems
secretly the same one so could it be
does the reason that we're stuck on all
of them even though they have different
running times maybe it's the same
okay and then you know maybe some one of
you will spend a lot of hours and figure
out one algorithm and that algorithm
will solve all our problems this is what
we want
[Music]
why are we stuck are we stuck for the
same reason so this is what we want to
achieve
so what I'm gonna do now is I'm going to
tell you just a little bit about some
traditional hardness and complexity and
why it doesn't quite work for us and
then we'll discuss the fine-grained
approach and then I'll give you one
example
of a reduction
let's try to do this first
okay so when we teach complexity courses
or take complexity courses we see
theorems of this nature this is a very
simple example for every integer C
there's some problem solvable and then
to the C time but not in N to the C
minus Epsilon time and this is just an
example for polynomial tile but this is
there's much more General theorems than
this so there exists problems for which
you can get some running time but
improving on this running time
substantially it would be impossible
now of course we don't care about the
existence of problems we care about
longest common subsequence or set or
batch partial match which are not these
problems which are very contrived in a
sense so we don't even know we don't
know how to show that our favorite
problem is not at this much time
for example we don't even know what how
to show that sat is not a linear time
yeah
I don't know
all right so here's another approach
from complexity Theory P versus NP uh we
believe for whatever reason p is not
equal to NP and it's a notoriously hard
problem we this is roughly what p and
NPR you all know that so we have this
beautiful theorem that says that case
hat is NP hard for okay at least three
and what it says is that if we really
believe that P is not equal to and P
then K sub doesn't have a polynomial
timeout
okay in other words uh making some
hypothesis
we can derive a lower Bound for set yeah
it requires super polynomial time
all right wonderful we have conditional
hardness now we made up a condition for
whatever reason we believe it and now we
immediately get hardness for set
okay so but
does this help us
no because
a problem is already in polynomial time
cannot be NP hard okay so uh problems
like the longest common subsequence
batch partial match we cannot prove
hardness for them in this way so we
gotta do something else so how do we
prevent P hardness we assume Pinot or
equal and NP then we show that if some
problem Q had a polynomial time
algorithm then you can solve every
problem and P in polynomial time and
therefore we conclude that Q requires
super pardon under time this is BSM
reduction all right and as I said no
problem that can already be solved in
polynomial time can be NP hard uh
because if we show NP hardness uh then
you would immediately get Picos NP so
there's no way to use this for our
purposes and instead
um
we have to do something else in other
words NP hardness is too coarse grained
because it doesn't care about the
running times in particular and
it's not useful to us
all right so I usually have to take an
aside and talk about why we as a
computer scientist say that polynomial
time is efficient okay nobody in
practice says polynomial time is
efficient because
stuff so n to the 10 is not and squared
is not and so on
um right because really why do we care
about that so we care about polynomial
time being efficient because well we can
completely disregard what model of
computation we use
whether you're working on two on a
touring machine on a Ram or whatever
your favorite pointer machine or
whatever you can translate between these
machine models it's a small polynomial
overhead so if you have an efficient
algorithm on one model then it's also
efficient in the other model we'll never
put it on your time means efficient so
it allows us to have this freedom and
Theory to forget about the Machine model
and it also has this thing that
polynomial of a polynomials a polynomial
which is extremely useful when you use a
polynomial time algorithm within a
polynomial time now we're going to it
stays polynomial so if you forget about
polynomial meaning efficient you have to
be more careful how you compose things
but in any case so what we're going to
do is we're going to take the idea for
mentally hardness this conditional sort
of hardness and
fix it so that it now cares about
concrete running times it won't be only
about putting them it will be about
quadratic cubic to to the end to the
square root of n whatever running time
we pick and we'll be careful about it
okay
so this finishes this part of the
introduction are there any questions at
this point
all right what is the fine grade
approach so what are we going to do is
going to take we're going to take NP
hardness is very silly way to look at it
and we're going to convert this into
something a little bit uh better suited
for our purposes so here we made this
this assumption that P is not equal to
NP for fine grain hardness we're going
to make different assumptions we're
going to pick
some problem H for example set and the
running time h of n for that problem and
we're going to assert that H requires h
of n time maybe you save some polylogs
here but you require you cannot do
better than that so you require h of n
to the one minus little o one time on
inputs of size n and you fix your
computational model for example the Ram
or you could pick a different
computational models here if you fix
your computational model pick a problem
you really believe is hard for whatever
reason
for this running time so this is the
type of hardness assumptions we'll take
instead of sat requires super put it on
your time which is the same as Pinot
regular p
the reduction so what the reductions
over here uh implied that if q a problem
Q has a polynomial time algorithm then
you could use that algorithm to solve
satin polynomial terms this is a very
rough consequence of the polynomial time
reductions and what our reductions will
have as a consequence is that
if a problem Q can be solved faster than
Q to the end time Q of n to the one
minus Epsilon time for you it's it's
running time Q then you could use that
algorithm on the ram to show that
problem H also has an improved algorithm
but for its running time
so this is not the definition of a
reduction it's the consequence that will
derive from the definition of the
reduction
um yes so
all right so for every episode there is
a Delta that's right and I will have a
formal definition a little bit and
Epsilon Delta can be very different
because there's the same one could be
bigger yeah
and after this from this concert
consequence similarly to here we'll
conclude that if you believe this
hypothesis then Q must require this much
time so the hypothesis will be about a
problem with this running time and the
conclusion will be about a different
running time
a different problem
okay so what I'm going to do oh yeah
great question yeah see if he's asking
how do you put H so I'll get to that you
have to be very careful how to speak
English but maybe Orion will spend most
of the night in the resolve H and then
you got to be careful
all right so here's one H okay uh
people have worked on Sat for many many
decades and this hypothesis actually has
appeared in the past so uh in polyester
and paturi and then Calabrese
it was given here as a hypothesis and it
was named over here so the hypothesis is
that for every Epsilon there's some
Clause with K so the K set and then
variables and clauses can't be solved in
two to the N minus to the one minus
Epsilon time basically so for every
episode I can give you with k for which
you cannot solve K set in this running
so basically case at this case grows
requires it to the end time
so this is one hypothesis you might pick
who knows what they would believe it
some people believe it some people don't
but the point is we don't know how to
prove or disprove
and maybe it's true
so we can use set but there's other
hypotheses we can make
oh notably this is much much stronger
not only is sets not in polynomial time
but you can't even beat the Brute Force
algorithm
that is true
so there's three other problems from
different communities that we often
prove like results from and finance
complexity so I'm going to Define them
on the next slide
so in all of these problems we will
assume the random access Machine model
with order log and bit words where n is
the size of the input
um and the three problems are the three
sum problems come from computational
geometry the all pair shortest pass
problem from graph algorithms and
orthogonal vectors which appears in many
places also it's equivalent to one of
the problems I mentioned earlier
threesome you have a set of n numbers
let's say they're integers and I want to
know if three of those integers sum to
zero
okay it's very easy to solve in N
squared time
we give it as a homework problem and
algorithms with hash tables is super
easy you throw the integers in a hash
table you can you compute every pair a
plus b and check whether the negation is
in the hashtag so the hash tables you
can do it there's also a
deterministically quadratic time
algorithm that does some sorting and
uses pointers
good question yeah what's the size of
that you put exactly of this case Okay
um assume that the integers fit in the
words in a word so their order login bit
integers and there's n number so the
size of the input is n log n order line
login
and in the word Ram model it can do word
operations at constant time so N squared
is
model
yeah this one is in the for integers so
I didn't get here yet but yes so but
Brandon Maine and Patricia in 2005 uh
showed that if your numbers are actually
integers uh you can shave a long and
squared off of that squared running time
and Chen showed that for real numbers
now in the real round model we have to
shake it uh you can get the same
and the hypothesis the hypothesis is
about the word Ram model and Order login
bits integer inputs
um is it is the threesome requires
quadratic plan n to the two minus little
or one point so you cannot get into the
1.999
if you don't believe it please it's true
that I want to see the new technique it
will be great
all right the other problem uh very
simple also so you have n vectors and
they're very short so they're over let's
say log squared then dimensions
very small and they're binary zero one
vectors and I want to know if there's a
pair of these vectors that are talking
about
okay
is there a pair That's orthogonal How
Can You Solve IT you try every pair of
vectors and compute them in a product
and you check is any one of them
approaches zero that's N squared times d
the best running time uh Ryan is one of
the authors there so they showed that
basically D is some constant times log n
you can get a sub quadratic time
algorithm now this this Factor here is
no longer a constant when D is more than
log n like log n
squared login times
well this is the best known algorithm
right now
and there's a hypothesis that in this
word model orthogonal vectors requires
quadratic time
you can't improve over this part
why should you believe it well there's
reasons so I'll tell you about these
reasons in a second so the third problem
is from graph algorithms all pair
shortest paths you have an uh end node
directed or undirected graph it has some
weights let's say they're positive
integers doesn't actually matter too
much you want to compute the distance
between every pair of nodes there's many
ways to solve it you can run Floyd War
show you can run Belmont far from every
no whatever any many algorithms and the
classical algorithm is running cubic
time
and Ryan again see he's been trying to
disprove them that's why I made a joke
earlier about it so he's also he also
has the best running time for all pair
sure this pass it runs in N cubed over
an exponential of square root log n so
if this were if this square root weren't
there then we would have a sub cubic
timer where number the square root was
there unfortunately so it's still
basically cubic the best one
so the hypothesis from graph algorithms
is that we cannot beat 10 Cube time
substantially by more than an enter a
little of one factor do you know if the
the distance or the weights make a big
difference here so what if you just need
to answer zero or one for every pair of
nodes if there is a path or not if there
is a path then it's easy so then if if
there is a pattern that's a Transit a
policy problem it can be solved with
matrix multiplication
so the weights really matter so in fact
there's a kind of a threshold the moment
the waves become roughly uh in terms of
roughly n uh that's where we can no
longer do better than keep it
so yeah why isn't this
modification for me
this one is
matrix multiplication problem over the
tropical semi ring so that's what it is
because
it's meant plus it's not our favorite
so all right so now let's go back here
um so Ryan's probably free to help me
slide so here it is again he says in
2005 he said well if you believe the
strongly exponential type hypothesis
then you better believe that orthogonal
vectors require quadratic time because
it turns out that any sub quadratic time
algorithm for orthogonal vectors can
solve set faster than two to the end
time
so this is actually even more believable
it could be that sat has a faster
algorithm yeah the orthogonal vectors
doesn't have a faster than quadratic
time algorithm so this one is strictly
more believable than Seth are you thank
you yes at the end of this lecture
at the end of the lecture I will show
you this proof because very nice
now I mentioned this batch partial match
problem and here I didn't mess up the
dimension so you have a database of
adventures with Dimension d and n
queries with some Stars uh you want to
know for every pair whether the every
query whether there's a something in a
database that matches it this is
actually completely equivalent to
orthogonal vectors they're actually the
same problem uh if you squint you'll see
it
so you can think about you know this
being one of the hardness hypothesis
problems
and one more thing there is this paper
that formulates a strengthening of the
strong exponential Prime hypothesis and
if now whether you believe it or not I
don't know but if you believe it then it
suggests that these three are not
equivalent so in particular
you can't reduce orthogonal vectors to
the other two that's what it shows under
some hypothesis
yeah so your equivalent do you mean
regarding to the specific runtimes We
Believe are optimal okay yes regarding
the specific part
okay
all right so these are the problems now
what are these problems that's uh you
know if you have other ideas go ahead
yeah
oh yeah
yeah yes good question
all right
let's go back to here so we I showed you
a few problems we decided to use as
hardness access problems they come from
different areas and different running
times uh but you know maybe there's many
more maybe these will be these
hypothesis could be false but still the
theory will still hold because it's
about reductions okay so now what I'm
going to tell you is the definition of
reduction so first I will remind you
what we typically teach in our undergrad
courses about polynomial time reductions
with respect to NP hardness and I'll
tell you how uh the new reduction should
be different it will be
so the first thing what do we usually do
and we teach these many one reductions
what are these many one reductions we
say A and B are some decision problems
so they're output of zero and one and we
say a is polynomial time many one
reducible to B if there's some
polynomial algorithm that transforms
every instance of a into some instance
of B so that a is a yes instance if and
only if B is an S is in other words
what are if I have an algorithm that
solves B I can just return the same
answer for a this is what many one
reductions do
they have many useful properties that we
exploit when we teach our hardness but
they have many weaknesses for example uh
you cannot reduce a function problem to
a decision problem this way
so decision problem has one and one bit
answer you can't just return so you have
to have many uh calls instead of one and
this can be fixed by not using a menu
one reduction but using a touring
reduction creating many instances
instead okay so that's also something we
will do
the other problem is that it's really
coarse grained so the reduction running
time is polynomial
and it can be an arbitrary polynomial
and so the size of B can be an arbitrary
polynomial and so there's no like it's
too coarse grain it doesn't uh just if
we even if we have like a quadratic time
algorithm over here it could translate
to a n to the 100 into the 1000 over
there it's not useful for our purposes
so we also have to change that
so now I'll give you uh the definition
of fine grain reduction which we had in
our 2010 paper a while back so what is
the intuition we have two problems A and
A and B and we have running times for
them little a of n a little B of N and I
want to reduce a to B so that if someone
can beat b of n as a running time here
get a better than b of end time
algorithm for B our reduction will give
us a better than a of n running time for
a so that's what we want to achieve so
let's do it
okay so we say a is a b reducible to B
if for every Epsilon there's some Delta
and an a of n to the 1 minus Delta time
algorithm
that blah blah blah blah blah there's a
picture okay so what what happens here
so we have for every instance of a of
size n
your reduction solves a by running a of
n to the 1 minus Delta time algorithm
which queries instances of B okay Oracle
course so so that if you can solve B
instantaneously then you also solve a by
by using the answers to be over here
and now we also have this very important
inequality that
B when is Epsilon the sum over there is
a of enter one minus Delta what does
this mean okay we said for every Epsilon
there's a Delta for every Epsilon
meaning if I had a better than b of n
time algorithm a b of n to the one minus
Epsilon time algorithm for B then I
could apply it over here
right and the running time of these
Oracle calls will be the sum of I over B
of N Sub I to the one minus Epsilon
that's the running time of The Oracle
calls and this inequality says that this
is less than a of n to the one minus
Delta which happens to also be the
running time of the reduction
so together the reduction together with
Oracle calls with their algorithm
applied to them will give me an order a
of n to the Y minus Delta time algorithm
to solve a
so for every Epsilon there's a Delta and
a reduction so that
if B is in B of n to the 1 minus Epsilon
time then a is an a event at 1 minus
Delta time
in the summation about uh
in order to check the reduction uh where
what is the range of I how much much you
can have many
in some relations can be many women can
it be more than n
it depends on your function
it depends on a and b
it can be really big but it depends so
it depends on the algorithms that you're
using for yeah so like if a is like an
actual video and the number of instances
as long as it be a small so you can be
pretty big uh the sizes of the instances
can also vary they don't have to be the
same okay
thank you
the definition
um and it has this nice composition
property if a is a b reducible to B and
B is BC reducible to C then a is a
Serial disabled C
because it makes sense
more questions about this
so the reduction can be adaptive right
oh absolutely that's what the Oracle
calls me so if I could produce this
Earth on the call depending on what the
answer to this one was you know
we really need it to prove something
all right so
now we have our harness High passes we
need we have this new notion of
reduction HQ finder and reduction with
this consequence
and then we we have to get actually
provide such reductions and we didn't
get a bunch of conditional hardness
results
so for LP hardness originally people
that uh car you know got 21 uh NP heart
problems and there's many many more that
kept added on and on and on and we would
like to be there uh but we're not quite
there and you also have problems that
are outside of NP the NP horn and so on
but our picture is more like this okay
so
we have these three or four problems
there's you can add more problems but
these are the central ones and you have
hypothesis for them so orthogonal
vectors requires basic p and square time
South basically two to the end threesome
and squared apsp little one cubed n is
the number of knowns but the input size
is N squared so really it's big n to the
1.5
and we have different things so let's
start with all pair shortest paths so in
our 2010 paper we use the notion of
reduction and showed that a large number
of problems are actually n cubed n cubed
equivalent to all pair shortest paths so
that means that a sub cubic time
algorithm for one of these problems
resolves all of them which is where we
want to be we actually want everything
to be equivalent but we're not there yet
so for example one thing that Nicole is
going to show you in her talk is that
this problem negative triangle is
equivalent to our pressure is power so
let me tell you the problem is because
it's faced very silly I thought for sure
has a nice algorithm but it doesn't okay
you have a graph and then nodes and you
have weights on the edges that can be
positive or negative let's say integers
and I want to know if there's a triangle
so three nodes so that the sum of the
edge weights is negative
cubic time is Trivial you just enumerate
all the triples of vertices and compute
the sum of the weights but we don't have
a better algorithm and it turns out that
if you did then all of a sudden all
pairs are just pass and all these other
problems also have a sub cubic time
algorithm so this sort of approach
allows you to identify
kind of the heart of a problem the
simplest thing that you can think of
that will make everything get get solved
if there is no connection between the
things yeah great question so threesome
is about exact equality so is is there
some that's exactly zero where this
one's less than
but there is a problem that is harder
than both and that's the exact triangle
problem where those sum of Weights has
to be exactly zero and I think in
general mentioned something about that
and he's stuck
okay so for orthogonal vectors because
the problem is so simple you can show
many many conditional lower bounds
assuming this hypothesis and for example
this longest common subsequence problem
I mentioned before you can reduce
orthogonal vectors to it in an N squared
N squared way so that if you improve the
quadratic time
uh dynamic programming algorithm for
longest common subsequence you can also
improve orthogonal vectors and get a
fast diagram for set
and more
but also many many other problems Nicole
and we'll talk a little bit about
diameter the graph diameter which is
related to this problem for threesome
for many years the computational
geometry Community looked at threesome
and they showed many many lower bounds
assuming the threesome requires
quadratic time their reductions weren't
fine-grained reductions but they were
pretty good they were more like many one
reductions so they create one instance
but they still got a huge number of
papers out of this in many many results
so more recently we've been able to show
that threesome reduces two other
problems that are not from geometry that
subsequence problems strength problems
and so on some sequence alignment
problems
there's many other results so the number
of results keeps growing there's things
about Dynamic problems that we'll
discuss later and so on
yeah and so on Monday we learned how to
get
overgoing into the three over two so why
is the problem of finding a negative
problem and keeping it okay so he said
uh a confined triangle is an M
the number of edges is what the three
over two is given and you can do the
same for negative triangle you can also
do it in N to the three over two uh in
the same same algorithm basically uh but
the
the regular triangle can result faster
than anything
so whereas this one we don't know how to
have
so uh so in general when we think about
the input we think about the input as
the size as so why does it make sense to
think about the interview
good good so he says uh the size of the
input we usually think about the whole
thing whereas for graphs sometimes we
only talk about and this is because for
graphs we often talk about dense graphs
so once you fix n the size of the input
is N squared basically and this the
definition I have you can adapt it for
any input measure it doesn't have to be
the size of them but it could be like
some other image like the number of
nodes and so on
so what happens can you cast all this
hypothesis in terms of M or would things
break and then yeah you can unpack it
where did I put it here
um you can so for yeah right here
this is your end
these two things are equivalent for this
problem yeah when your best algorithm is
the Brute Force often therefore
I think you want to highlight the fact
that in defense grass we have this nice
equivalence in this course case that's a
good yeah that's right if you in the
sports case this equivalence
we have different things for sparse
graphs because because the notion of
reductions kind of changes when you
change the measure like the reduction is
the same for the parameters
okay good question
all right
I defined this
so my next goal oh did you have a
question
okay yeah yeah
so what I'm going to do next is I'm
going to give you the reduction
from sat to orthogonal Vector so you can
see that if you believe the strong
exponential time it process then you
should believe orthogonal vectors
requires quadratic time or in other
words if you solve orthogonal vectors
faster than organic time then you
resolve set
a reminder what is orthogonal vectors
you have n binary vectors of small
Dimension and to the literal one let's
say the S1 up to SN are there two
vectors s i and SJ so that their inner
product is zero
equivalently are the two vectors so that
in every coordinate coordinate C either
as I is zero and according or as J is
zero in that coordinate that's because
they're binary
okay
there's a Brute Force algorithm I
mentioned N squared which is n to the
two plus little one because the
dimension is small and the best known
algorithm is this
and we'll show this theorem over here if
OV had an N to the two minus Epsilon
time algorithm for any Epsilon that you
pick
then set this false
Seth again for every Epsilon there's a
case or the K satellite variables and M
Clauses cannot be solved in 2 to the one
minus Epsilon times n time
in other words if you had a better than
to the End of Time algorithm for some
Epsilon that can solve set for all k k
Sapphire okay then set is false so we
need the same Epsilon to work for all
the case
and this is a theorem
start
let F be a formula and N variables the
name Clauses in CNF form
for example this one
OV
are there there's a set of n vectors Big
N will be the number of vectors and
little n is the number of variables okay
um and N vectors in small Dimension you
want to know if two orthogonal what we
want to do is given this formula we want
to create a set of vectors in small
Dimension so that there is an orthogonal
pair if and only if f is satisfiable
and we want the number of vectors to be
roughly 2 to the N over 2. and the
dimension small so if you have the
number of vectors to be roughly 2 to the
N over 2 in small Dimension then a sub
quadratic time algorithm and this will
be a less than two to the N algorithm
forsa
so we'll use this nice approach that
takes the variables and splits them into
two halves of n over two each
and now this 2 to the N over 2 part over
here should give you an idea what to do
with the send over two things we have to
enumerate some something okay so what do
we do
well for every for V1 let V1 be the
first part of the variables and V2 the
second part we're going to enumerate all
partial assignments to the variables in
V1 and all partial assignments the
variables of V2
okay so the they're two to the N over 2
for each of them
arbitrary I don't know how to do better
with a special partition but you
arbitrarily split them
okay so for example if I pick V1 here V1
is X1 and X2 the first two variables I
look at the partial assignments V1 X1 is
set to zero X2 is set to zero x one is
zero x two is one and so on there's four
of them all right
now for every
choice of V1 or V2 and every partial
assignment Phi for VJ will create a
vector whose length is the number of
Clauses M plus two and let's call this
vector v of J and Phi Phi is the partial
assignment J is the choice of one and
two which picks whether you're taking
the first half or the second half of the
variables
here's how we'll pick it so for V1 the
first two coordinates will be zero one
and then you have a coordinate for every
clause
okay and what do you put there so
remember uh we we have a fixed partial
assignments to V1 and we're going to
look at each Clause let's say this one
and we're going to put a zero if that
partial assignment satisfies the clause
and we'll put a 1 if it does not satisfy
the cost
we do the same for the second half of
the variables except over here instead
of zero zero one we put one zero so
again we check does this this satisfy
this Clause this is the partial channel
is satisfied and we put a zero if it
doesn't want if it doesn't
so here's an example right we have this
formula over here V1 is this and V2 is
the second half x three and let's say we
want to form the the
vector corresponding to the first half
of the variables X1 and X2 for the
partial assignment where X1 and X2 are
set to zero the first two coordinates
are zero one because we're talking about
the first half of the variables and then
we look at each clause for the first
Clause we check does the partial
assignment zero zero satisfy the Clause
no so we put a one
does the partial assignment 0 to X1 and
0 to X to satisfy this Clause yes
because not X1 is one so this one's
satisfied so then I put a zero here
because it's satisfied and in the final
one X1 and X2 do not appear at all
okay so there no matter what assignment
I pick for them this will not be
satisfied so I'll put a 1.
this is clear and very easy to to
construct these vectors
ZN over two times
all right
there you go so the first thing is that
if I have two vectors that correspond to
the same
half of the variables let's say to V1
then their inner product will not be
zero because two they'll both have a one
in this coordinate if if they're in in
the second if they correspond to the
second half of the variables they both
have one in the first quarter and so
again they're an upper orthogonal so the
only possible way there orthogonal is if
one is for V1 and the other one is for
the two
now we look at every Clause
orthogonality means that for every
Clause at least one of them is zero okay
but at least one of the meanings being
zero means that at least one of Phi of
PSI satisfies the clause
so two
V one Phi and V2 Phi are orthogonal if
and only if together if I am PSI form a
satisfying assignment so forever because
for every Clause at least one of them
satisfies
so the set of vectors we created has an
orthogonal pair if and only if the SAT
formula is satisfiable
the number of vectors is 2 times 2 to
the little n over two and the dimension
is the number of Clauses plus two
this is an LV instance so if you had for
example an N to the 2 minus Delta times
poly D Prime algorithm for orthogonal
vectors on N Dimension and D dimensions
and then vectors you would get a 2 to
the little one two times one minus Delta
over two polyam time algorithm percent
and then
yeah
okay yeah in this particular case this
is a mini one reduction right yes this
is a menu one reduction you will see a a
real fine grain reduction in the next
lecture I believe so there is nothing to
be gained by the by the fact that it's a
mini one reduction I mean it sounds
nicer because it's I mean it's very
clean
but uh yeah and sometimes you can you
can prove some things
many of the things
yes
it makes sense to look at the other
direction of purification as well like
if you have a slow opinion
you want to say can we reduce uh SAS to
uh orthogonal vectors two sets yes I've
tried and it failed
but there you need to have a menu and
you can do it with a manual reduction so
you would need some sort of a full fine
grain reduction where you create a ton
of little instances
uh so that like like a two to the nine
over two or two to the point nine nine
algorithm and then will be still fast
enough to beat quadratic right so the
little end that you get there has to be
very tiny I'm so proud but I I just
couldn't do it I think maybe you tried
too
do you think there's some some things
there needs to be some amazing
compressible similar to how like CNN's
representations
but like in the full generality of
Campus
it might also not be possible
maybe just maybe your OB is just harder
um yeah so I think
actually I'm a little fast today because
I'm I'm gonna finish early but if you
have any questions you know
[Applause]
um I was wondering if this is
um do you know if your framework is
easily extendable to the case where you
have an additional external data
structure that allows you to
uh sort of as an oracle or something
like that I'm thinking like what if you
have an index in a database or something
like that
[Music]
so so like in both problems you have a
database or
well in the beginning of the talk you
talked about uh we have these problems
with these with these upper bounds and
we don't know how to improve them now of
course if for some of these problems if
you already have something in place
which is uh on on your data and then and
then you you query or or whatever then
you can then you can answer some of
these problems more efficiently right
for example
if you have a two-hole index or
something like that in place and then
and your query asks about reachability
of two nodes you just have to do one
join instead of doing a whole path or
something like that yeah if you thought
about say things like this uh I mean I
guess in a sense the
only give the lecture on Dynamic
algorithms that's about data structures
but it's not when I talk about a room
only between like two problems that both
have data structures I'll show you this
how you can reduce one of these two
structure type problems
uh but yeah that's also a good question
I I do think the framework does extend
you have to
be more careful
nope
just a conceptual question so this fine
grain complexity as far as I understand
is based on
identifying some problems and looking at
all problems that are reducible to them
via these deductions so the classes that
arise from these are
based on one problem as opposed to
having them defined by some other
resources and here has this been dried
ahead talk to Amira then a little bit
about this and the question was whether
we can have a descriptive complexity of
fine grain complexity I think you've
done a little bit you know they had a
very nice
what is what is this somebody else let's
make sense and how fast
foreign
logic and you and you say uh model
checking on this like how complicated is
it
like just on the logical drafts or
something
and you can say what is the hardest uh
query problem to solve here
I have some favorite about the dense
case
but some of these problems
logic or something right
yeah it would be nice to have an outfit
but not not all some of them you can
describe a lot of things but not
so high
yeah but we should have a talk about
this
do you improve anything about matrix
multiplication under
application or matrix multiplication
we can prove some equivalences to matrix
multiplication and there's some Notions
uh but but maybe maybe matrix
multiplication isn't quadratic time uh
so I mean I don't know building your
time and the size of the input and then
I
don't know but assuming it is not you
can show about your relationships to
other problems
um
interesting
because
the reduction between the basic
hypothesis
to connect them somehow because right
now they are having the benefits drive
and then there are other hypothesis as
well that are introduced so we're
actively working
we have problems we can reduce all three
of them too we can we have problems you
can use two of them to put another the
second like assuming some conjectures
we're trying
and under some assumptions anyway I
guess we have to give yet another talk
on this and we didn't have time
yeah how do you pick the computational
model is there any type of income
certification we'll just pick the one
that people stand your usually study in
algorithms but again we think you can
change it then you have to be careful
that your reduction can run at the
appropriate time in that model yeah
that's a good question
did you mentioned that you cannot what
is the normal reviews
specifically because there is
uh I mean there's there's some papers
that give equivalences between various
other problems and exponential points
I think we can probably do that I don't
think anyone else published anything uh
but it won't be natural yeah so just to
provide evidence in the sensors
we believe that cannot be done
I'm not sure
thank you oh maybe this program
any other questions
if not uh please come back
[Applause]